and welcome to hannity on this busy
breaking news night now
tonight and every night this program we
bring you important information
that we're pretty confident you're not
going to get anywhere else from the
media mob
uh this show i am a member of the press
i am a talk show host i
embrace as a talk show host many roles
um
i like to say the show's like the entire
newspaper
we do plenty of hard news in other words
no opinion whatsoever
i can produce thousands and thousands of
hours of it ground
breaking investigative reporting radical
associations of obama the deep state
we talk about sports we talk about
culture we talk about
entertainment and yes i give my opinion
on the issues of the day like
an op-ed page an editorial page and this
is important
i am upfront we on this show are up
front and honest
about this program and having a
conservative perspective
i believe in the things i'm passionate
about unfortunately though
well the vast majority of people in the
media they are not
up front and they are not honest they
pretend to be
fair and balanced and pretend to bring
you only the truth
with no opinion they pretend their
opinions are actually
facts and they're not they even
sometimes refer to themselves as
quote fact checkers that need a fact
checking
but almost all so-called journalists
on other network and cable news shows
they're liberal socialist democrats
they're extension of all things the new
greendale radical socialists
they are biased they are partisan they
are political operatives
take fake jake tapper george
stephanopoulos actually worked for
democrats
before transitioning becoming newsmen
and
what they left their opinion at the door
no i'm not buying it
every day you have these hacks trying to
shape public opinion but
under the guise of journalism one of
their favorite methods by the way is
called
bias of omission for example
let's just take a look at hunter biden's
laptop from hell
now this week the daily mail uncovered
numerous texts from that laptop
it featured hunter biden's frequent use
of the
n-word hunter repeatedly called his
white lawyer the n-word
quote n-word you better not be charging
me hennessy race and quote
well that's what i'm saying n-word true
that n-word hunter even sent around a
meme referring to barack obama
former president as the n-word this is
obviously
despicable racist language remember the
mob in the media
they've been obsessed with all things
race and racism for years
so you might think this is a huge deal
couple of weeks ago
well last week as a matter of fact joe
was reminding us that racism
is the biggest threat to this country
okay
now don't forget the media was outraged
remember nascar driver kyle larson
for using similar language the media was
outspoken
they were outraged at the country music
star morgan wallen
he used the n-word also outraged at
major league soccer coach for singing
along with a song that had
n-word in the lyrics but for the
50-year-old crack smoking influence
peddling son
of the president of the united states no
outrage
whatsoever none zero zip
as a matter of fact as of late this
afternoon there was zero
mentions of hunter using the n-word
on fake news cnn msdnc
abc cbs nbc wasn't in the washington
post wasn't in the new york times not a
word
but for five plus years these same
so-called objective news outlets
well they saw racism around every corner
every statement from president trump
even
if they had to slice dice and edit
like in the case of charlottesville
which we talked a lot about take a look
it should come as no surprise
that we grapple every day with what it
means to have a president stained by
racism
a news organization says that it is
perfectly fine
to call donald trump racist we can truly
say his words have absolutely emboldened
white supremacists he has given oxygen
to racists
he is clearly trying to ignite a civil
war in this country
the question is what do you call someone
who says clearly racist things
this morning the answer is mr president
a lot of people are leveling a very
serious charge at him
so i asked him about it
are you racist i'm the least racist
person
that you have ever met so if i'm not
mistaken the media mob thinks everything
donald trump or conservative does or a
republican does is racist but
if you're a biden and you use the n-word
or you openly worry about
quote public schools becoming quote
racial jungles and try to stop
integration of our public school system
and stop busing
uh the liberal media you get a pass
and even worse if you're an african
republican
well you can go on fake news cnn you
better be prepared to be attacked
and today republican congressman byron
donalds he appeared on fake news cnn
to discuss the congressional black
caucus apparently blocking him from
joining
now the indignant cnn fake news host who
apparently thinks
that she speaks for the entire
african-american community
accused donald's of being out of step
with their
cause i guess the expert on all these
matters
you decide do you think that your
defense of a person that said
things like that might be incongruent
with the mission of the cbc
first of all whatever the president said
in the past it's nothing to do with this
discussion at all
i think well you've defended you've
defended it you've defended please don't
cut me off i didn't i have not cut you
off in this interview please do not do
that to me
thank you as a black man in america i'm
allowed to have my own thoughts on who i
choose to support and who i choose not
to support
my support for president trump whether
it's for or against is irrelevant that
has nothing to do with this discussion
this is whether the ideology of somebody
who is conservative
is welcome in the congressional black
caucus it's really that simple
checkmate now by the way is it called
the congressional black caucus
or the congressional liberal black
caucus
because you see what's happening here
fake news cnn almost every other outlet
narrative is more important than truth
they have an agenda
their long-running narrative is
republicans are evil racist
monsters uh they don't want you to know
that president trump signed off oh
on the bill that permanently provided
more money to historically black
colleges than any other president
250 million dollars a year i doubt they
gave trump a lot of credit when he
signed the first step act
reducing the incarceration of many
minorities serving lengthy sentences
for nonviolent crimes overturning joe
biden's crime bill
they don't want you to know that under
trump more african-american hispanic
americans were employed
with the lowest unemployment rates
record after record after record
shattered
the media mob democrats want you to
believe that president trump is an
evil heartless monster who forcibly
cleared
peaceful black lives matters protesters
from lafayette
square park so that he could get a photo
op in front of historic st
john's church you might remember this
when they dispersed protesters in
lafayette park the other day when the
president wanted his photo op
police fired tear gas on peaceful
protests outside the white house
all so donald trump could stage a photo
op
because the president literally wanted a
photo op after all this tear gas had
been sprayed on
u.s american citizens last night those
peaceful protesters in dc
were cleared from the park you'll
remember so that president trump
could walk across the street to st
john's church
for a photo op the united states
government does not use the military
against civilians in this country unless
there's a damn good reason
and all we ended up with was what the
president of the united states looking
like
a wannabe dictator right uh so he could
walk over over to a church
and pretend to be concerned about the
church
well guess what none of that was true
all of what they said were lies just
like three years trump russia collusion
they lied to the entire country
according to a brand new inspector
general report
u.s park police were already in the
process of
clearing the park before they ever
learned about donald trump's
visit to the church they were dispersing
demonstrators
to install new fencing before donald
trump went there
after the protest became violent and the
church was lit on fire
but according to america's genius
journalists trump bad republicans bad
conservatives bad
riot is good even today it perplexed
fake news jim acosta
he just couldn't admit the truth even
now take a look
well i certainly think it raises more
questions than it answers i mean
you know the the ig report is saying
that the park police
cleared the park with the purpose of
setting up this fence when i read
through this report it sounded as if
this inspector general was auditioning
to become
the inspector general at mar-a-lago
because
i mean this is almost a whitewash of
what occurred
on june 1st jim acosta is auditioning to
be the leader of
aoc squad because he's that far radical
left
you'll get the truth from jim unless it
fits his
liberal radical democratic socialist
narrative like so many journalists in
the mob though you know fake news acosta
his support for the democratic party is
far more important than
actually telling you the american people
the truth hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else